my lord uh
this is my uh appeal
uh against the
judge below's refusal of uh interim
relief
i appear for the appellants
with my london friends uh mr pogba joy
miss mitchell miss sheridan and mr
bordell
milan and friends
mr dunlop queen's council miss barnes
and miss reeve
appear for the secretary of state and
then friends miss davinski queen's
council mr bondok mr and miss patina
appear for the united nations high
commissioner
for uh refugees
uh my lords you will see that my lords
my lady you will see that we have three
uh grounds of appeal
um i will address you on them in order
the first ground concerns the judge's
approach
to whether or not there was a serious
issue to be tried we submit
that he erred in his assessment
of the appellant's case this is a
pure legal question
and if somehow it's not
he was plainly wrong
and the strength of the case
is relevant to the consideration
of the balance of
convenience and to the extent that this
is
controversial i'll come back to it but
i'll simply give you
a couple of references if i may
firstly
lord hoffman
in the national commercial bank of
jamaica case
and you have that at supplementary
authorities tab 13
page
397 that's the head note
and that and then pages
405
and paragraph 18
and page 402
paragraph 21 we cited that authority
before the judge
below
that's our submissions through relief
interim relief bundle 111
paragraph talk the second case
is also her majesty's board the case my
lord or justice singh may remember he
appeared in this this is the congo case
and it's lord walker
supplementary authority
2
page 20
paragraph 40
lord walker for the board lord hoffman
for the board in those two cases both
say
you can look at the strength of the case
to determine uh balance of convenience
the first case is a civil it's a
commercial case the second case is the
judicial review case to the extent i
have to go there
i i would say in the public law context
because cyanomid principles are adjusted
and there is a priori weight given to
the public body acting in the public
interest is all the more important
for the court to be able to look at
questions of weight
if if that rule is narrow to the point
that
you can only do so when it's clear
we say
that on grounds certainly on grounds of
one
that
ground
four
and ground seven
of our judicial review grounds it was
absolutely clear
and with that please may i
address you on the strength of ground
one
which is
the proposition
that the secretary of state
her assessment of the situation at
rwanda
that it was in general safe
for the purposes of rule 345b
was tame side non-compliant
and irrational
because
into radia
it was predicated
on a profound misunderstanding
to put it at its lowest
of the unhcr's position
and it would fall to be quashed for that
reason alone
irrespective of whether or not
there is a real risk of reform
in a six-week period or whatever period
you have
but on classic public law principles
it is clear
that the secretary's general assessment
would fall to be quashed and this on any
view
we submit
given how strong the case was on that
point
would have very considerable relevance
for the balance of convenience but the
judge gave it none
so uh my lord my lady my lord's my lady
can i please take you to
the secretary of state's general
assessment
which is it which is
interim brief bundle page one five three
so it begins the document begins at page
one four seven
yes
and if you please
uh the the key judgments as it were
are set out at 1 5 1
we had argued that the secretary of
state's own
assessment of the key judgments
couldn't rationally support the overall
conclusion that rwanda was safe
by the time of the hearing before the
judge
on friday
the ground was much stronger than that
because it was abundantly clear
that the serial failures
that the secretary of state herself had
had recognized meant that the unhcr's
consistent view
in fact had been
that rwanda was not safe
and we see that
from
2.1.1 at page 153 my lord's my lady
where it is said that a functioning
asylum process is in operation
at 2.2
uh 2.1.2 rwanda is a signatory has a
long history of receiving significant
numbers
uh 2.1.3
has a track record of working
constructively with domestic and
international partners including the
unhcr
and
over the page at one point
at 2.22
the government
doesn't provide legal assistance to
asylum seekers during the first instance
process however
unhcr
does if required
uhcr provide advice on the asylum
process
and at
2.13 13.3161
at the bottom of the page no credible
evidence
to suggest
that asylum seekers have been returned
to the countries
where they had a well-founded
persecution one possible exception was
provided by unhcr of two libyans it
isn't clear that the individual sought
to claim asylum
now none of that with great respect is
accurate none of it
and i'll show you why in a moment could
you just give me the last paragraph
number again uh yes my lord it is uh two
point
thirteen point three
page one uh one six one thank you
and
and we see
that
uh in her
uh
pac response
the secretary of state
submitted through her
legal team
uh at
page
653 if you're still in that bundle
paragraph twenty eight
sorry six four six did i get the picture
six four six thank you
uh
paragraph 28
third sentence some individual examples
of concern
sorry second sentence in this respect to
the secrets assessment echoes that of
the united cr which observed last year
that in rwanda there is a general
respect for the principle of reformal
uh some of the individual examples of
concern were noted by the cpit but they
reached a rational and reasonable
conclusion which was consistent with the
view of the unhcr
in parenthesis no it absolutely was not
and it was consistently communicated to
the secretary of state that it was not
you see that from a document that was
produced
on friday at two o'clock that it was not
the case at all
that in rwanda both the principle of
monroe fulmore and the prohibition of
removal violating rights free from
torture et cetera it will respect it
and
we
respectfully submit
that it's clear it was clear even from
the material that the secretary of state
had it became clearer as i said
by friday
that these claims were either false or
based on a manifestly inadequate entire
inquiry and can i please i'm sorry to
jump around in the bundles but
i should have said we're very grateful
to the speed with which you've
accommodated us
uh and
it's meant that the bundles aren't as
streamlined as they should be
um if i could please take you to the
core bundle at 372
and this is where
there is an interview
with the unhcr in kigali
on the 21st of march of this year what
do you mean by the four bundle
ah
is that is that the post issue no it's
it's the judicial review for bundle do
you not have that
i think don't think anyone sent us that
electronically i'm afraid i don't think
anyone sent us that electronically
uh do you we have the
entering
relief we have the interim relief bundle
we have and we also have the post-issue
documentation bundle those are the two
main factuals these are the two main
ones
and we have the unhcr's materials
we
were under the impression that represent
the same time at 11 48 on saturday if
you give us the reference mr saying i
don't want to take it
i'm very grateful we've all got limited
time this morning
to do
i don't want to waste it
you give us the reference i will give
you the reference one so this was an
interview conducted in march of this
year
unfortunately cards down not cards up
unhcr weren't told
that
uh the rwanda plan was in prospect
and this is what they said even in that
context um and the reference is 372 once
you get it phase 372. your hcr are not
in involved at all
at all
in the national refugee status
dissemination committee
uh unhcr cannot provide the support
it thinks is it's needed
and that's it
uh extracted my lord you do my daily you
do have that in the interim relief
bundle at page 182
and then we see
um
if i can take you please
to the minute i referred to
so
this was a minute
this is your post
issue bundle please
and it is
the
uh
it's a minute that's appended to
the statements of daniel hobbs at page
74.
you have that uh just just bear with me
yes 77 is the email age 74
74 is a statement it should be the
statement yeah and then it should be
appended to that at page 77 26th of
april 26th of april now is it i think
it's important that i explain if i may
the genesis of
uh this meeting and how we
came to how it appears before you
uh nobody knew about this meeting
i'm sorry no no nobody on our side of
the courtroom knew about this meeting
um
uh miss stabinsky was
alerted to the fact that there had been
this meeting
past midnight
on the thursday
and she alerted
i think the secretary of state to that
and then we got this meeting
at two o'clock on friday the notes of
this meeting
and
just on the question of reform
you will see
that
what the unhcr are saying to the
secretary of state
is that
in the sec
the third bullet
they had several concerns and this is a
meeting with the head of the unhcr in
rwanda
they had several concerns about rwanda's
process
they claimed people from the middle east
were currently systematically rejected
in their claims
the
live appellant
in this
appeal is an iraqi national
i should have made it clear that the
fourth appellant's his removal direction
has been cancelled yes
and that's it that's since the judgment
below
since the judgment dilemma and i think
you will have seen that
four claimants had their removal
directions cancelled
another
two had been cancelled before we issued
i think through the friday
yeah there are now i was going to make a
submission about the fact that there are
only 11 people on the plane yes
it may even be
that there are fewer than that now
according to our times this morning
which may not be accurate of course
so so the the third bullet several
concerns around this process they claim
people from the middle east uh
systematically rejected
systematically rejected in their claims
that's on a prima facie
assessment basis
no my lady the prima facie assessment
basis is with regard to neighboring
countries such as burundi i see
it's precisely the prima facie basis
that historically unhcr said well they
respect principles of performance
individually there are huge concerns
and so when you've got individual
discrimination
judais case is there is there is
systematic bias
systematic bias
and this is not disclosed to us
until friday at 2pm
after mrbitsky alerts the court to it
and the other side in the morning of the
hearing
second bullet for
those whose claims were refused they
asked whether they'd be returned to
unsafe countries according to them
they've been three recent cases of
reformer
return to countries unhcr advised
against uh obviously also have a status
determination determination function
under the general set their general
under their statute the 1950 statute
including two to afghanistan
and so forth
they raised concerns about independence
of the appeal process
serious concerns over capacity
i will come back
to another reason why this is very
significant
because this post states the mou
and the note the ball
which also the ball
wasn't published it was disclosed
in pap responses but it wasn't published
so
organizations such as the unhcr
ngos such as human rights watch amnesty
international couldn't scrutinize it and
that is something which
as justice meeting has commented upon in
different contexts he said if you've got
material relevant to safety of this kind
you've got to publish it
the notepad was never published
it was disclosed but never published
i think the chronologists uhcr were
asking for it from monday
last week they only received it i think
at the hearing in the during the hearing
on the monday on the friday
so
this post dates
that meeting and
the mou
and the
ball
by some 12 days
but i i'm in danger of of going out of
turn
can i just please take you to
unhcr's analysis of the position which
they bring together
in a document that is in this same
bundle
uh at page
22
26.
so the document
begins
20 doesn't it sorry the document begins
at 21. sorry
do you have that
it's exhibit lb1
edge 19
and i'm sorry it's 20.
you want to see our analysis
so which page are you on i'm on page 20
my lords yeah i have them
and
the relevant passages begin
from uh paragraph 11 onwards
and if i could just
shoot through those
paragraph eleven unity on notes that
whilst
rwanda has generally provided safe haven
to refugees for decades and made efforts
to build a pacific asylum system its
national asylum system is still
nascent
there is a serious risk that the burden
of processing asylum claims a new
arrival
arrivals from the uk could further
overstretch the capacity
of the rwanda national
asylum system
12 they say that the
mou should be legally binding at 14 they
say that it is necessary to have access
to fair and efficient procedures
procedures then there are comments about
um the procedures at the uk's end at 16
they say they place an excessive onus on
the asylum seeker essentially to
displace
the general view that the secretary
state has taken
and then at 17
they say that they have serious concerns
that asylum seekers transferred from the
uk to rwanda will not have access to
fair and efficient procedures for the
determination of refugee status with
consequent risks of reform
the structures are still in development
rwanda has primarily provided protection
to asylum seekers from neighboring
countries on a prima facie basis that's
my lady's point a moment ago
and then
it is
at the end of the page on on 21 uh 23
sorry it is your xcr's assessment that
long-term
and fundamental engagement is required
to develop rwanda's national asylum
eligibility structures with sustainable
capacity to efficiently adjudicate
individual asylum claims through fair
and consistently accessible structures
uh procedures sorry
and then
this paragraph 18 uhcr has expressed
concerns with regard to shortcomings in
the capacity of the rwandan system in
its july 20 submissions
with both the rwanda
and uk authorities
corp the concerns include a arbitrary
denial of access
to the procedures
with the consequential risk of detention
and in recent incidents of
chain reformal
b discriminatory access
c concerns about impartiality
with high rates of rejection d lack of
representation by a lawyer e
reasons for negative decisions not being
provided
f appeals
our
to a non-independent body
no precedent for appeals to the high
court
one eligibility officer
h insufficient access to interpreters
i need for an objective assessment of
the fairness and efficiency procedures
followed by a range of capacity capacity
development interventions
sustained capacity building
training
at j
your hcr has been unable to systematic
systematically monitor
the quality of decision making in
compliance with procedural standards
over the past years uacr has not been
permitted to observe the rsd committee
that's a refugee status determination
committee and information on asylum
cases is not shared systematically with
the unhcr by the rewind and authorities
and you have the comments that i've
shown you in the general assessment that
units
thinks everything is fine and it is
supervising the process it can offer
help
it's
absolutely plainly wrong
no question
and then 20
your hcr has concerns that cyber seekers
relocated from the uk to rwanda may not
be treated in the courts with accepted
international standards for example in
the context of protests by refugees in
rwanda against food ration cuts
in 2018
12 individuals were killed 66 were
arrested and some remained detained
unhcr is concerned that first persons of
concern relocated may be at significant
risk of detention and ill treat and
treatment not unconscious international
should they express
dissatisfaction through protests
lordship's relationship may be aware
there have been protests here at the
prospect of um
removal individuals sub-facing removal
have been on hunger
uh and then at the end of 21 uh
effectively depriving this is a passage
on article 31 i'll skip that for now
effectively depriving asylum seekers of
access to a fair and efficient deter
sign determination and treatment in line
with international standards is not
permissible as it may expose them to the
risk of reform and other rights
violations
it doesn't end there my lords my lady
the secretary of state
has applied her erroneous understanding
of unhcr's position
to individual decisions
um i can give you
a reference
in this bundle
to
appellant for who's now
uh
not uh live anymore in this appeal
but it is pro forma and illustrative
that's mom syria exactly my lord and the
reference is
uh
3 3
4
of this bundle
[Applause]
so the
this is a decision that begins at three
to
eight um
and it is a
the consideration of reform or and so
forth
is that paragraph 19331
there is a reference to a case of e.m
eritrea 29 at 333.
just bear with me i'm at 328 yes
could your lordship please go to 333
yes
and at the middle of the page
29 you'll see em eritrea in bold yes
and your lawsuit will recall that the
ameritra is a case about a transfer to
an eu member state
as the letter itself recognizes at
paragraph 30
and
there is
as various propositions from that case
are extracted
lord kerr's
judgment in euro ameritrade it was
b
need to look at
systematic failings
in the context of an eu member state and
we'll see over the critical
critical passages for my purposes are
over the page at three three four
where
completely falsely
the secretary says
the end of 31
the euro hcr is closely involved with
the medp
and will provide oversight of
individuals located relocated from the
uk
but with great respect no they won't and
that's now been accepted that that was
incorrect
there is a state statement there's an
apology
there's an apology
and at 32
it is noted that the unhcr has not
stated that there are systematic
failures well yes they
have
in in in minutes that were not produced
until last friday they did
systematic bias
have not stated there are systematic
failures or serious operational
difficulties well yes they have
capable of rebutting the presumption of
compliance with the mou nor has the
unhcr submitted correspondence well
that's fine drafting because they may
not have submitted correspondence by
this time
but they certainly communicated their
views
hasn't submitted correspondence
highlighting substantial concerns over
the asylum system in rwanda which it
supports well no it doesn't
well in any meaningful sense
either descriptively or normatively
it doesn't support it and
there is an identical passage in your
interim relief bundle with regard to
the fourth claimant before mr justice
swift and the i'll just give you the
reference
and it's at
page
351
power forty three
and three five seven
i can't be right sorry it's power forty
one and forty three there's an identical
passage in another it's very clear it's
a pro forma
and then
you see
uh mr
uh botnick's letter
where he complains of inaccuracies and
that's at pib 28 to 29
he says at no stage has unhcr agreed to
be involved in the arrangement whether
in the oversight capacity or otherwise
he says that unhcr has highlighted the
shortcomings of the rwandan system on a
number of occasions
including in july 2020 directly to the
london authorities in the course of
interviews
and as my lady uh observed the secretary
has effectively conceded this ground
because mr
the
hob statement
the statement that appends the minute
apologizes
at paragraph eight
page 76
concerns with certain letters sent to
those with the removal directions for
the 14th june flight have been brought
to my attention investigations were made
confirmed confirmed that errors were
made in seven letters responding to
human rights claims that
mischaracterized the role of the unhcr
in the
rwandan asylum system
i can confirm that this was an error
resulting from a misreading of the
secret report that's a report that i
took you to we respectfully submit that
this is very telling it absolutely
concedes ground one
but it's it doesn't go far enough we
respectfully submit
it is the general secret assessment
we submit that is clearly of central
relevance because it can if it does it
informs everything that follows it
near dispositively
or certainly
significantly informs the individual
decision because if you think about it
the individual is given seven days to
displace the views that the secretary
has arrived at in the general assessment
which raises issues about adequacy and
so forth
but
the point that i want to make here is
that it is not the case that the error
resulted from a misreading of the report
it's the report that's misleading
this decision that has faithfully and
accurately
implemented followed took
as their starting point their
considerable starting point the general
assessment as you would expect them to
do
and it's that general assessment that is
misleading it won't do to say well we've
got these seven letters
that we and they have misread it just so
happens that everybody in identical
terms has misread the general assessment
not at all
it's the general assessment that is
misleading
and so we say that at paragraph 26
the
judge below erred
in concluding
that ground one gave rise to a serious
tribal issue
but was not of compelling strength
the documents you've taken us through
for the last 10 minutes or so
can i
take it but you took the judge through
those
uh al almost
almost verbatim
in fact if i may be very frank
i cut and pasted sections of my speaking
note into my speaking note for you
certainly by reference to i started
and spent a lot of time
reading the analysis note
that appears
that i just took you to
that appears
just french
age 20. thank you mother yeah
exactly thank you
yes
yes mr pogba reminds me that the record
of meeting
i had to
deal with in reply i had to read it
as mr gullip was on his feet because it
was produced to us around two o'clock
in the afternoon
i i saw it after the hearing could be
commenced
um
my lord derek there my was my lady there
are
two further uh grounds where we say that
the judge uh
in saying that
he he said that ground four and round
seven were did not raise uh serious uh
tribal issues uh that's our skeleton
argument at uh paragraph nine they refer
to
this that that ground speaks to article
31
he essentially held that big because
my clients had not come directly in the
literal sense
there was no
merit to that ground that with respect
ignores the fact that
the views of the drafters in the travel
partois
the views of every academic that looks
that's looked at this issue in great
respect
the views of the unhcr and the views of
lord justice simon brown in a case
called adibi
and lord bingham in ask for are to the
contrary
and and those and the view is
essentially that some element of choice
is indeed open to refugees
the demi is authorities below
tab eight
page one seven two some element of
choice is indeed open to refugees any
merely short-term stopover on route to
intended sanctuary cannot forfeit the
protection of article 31. can i just
have the reference again sorry my lord i
went too quickly it's the authorities
below this is the case of the demi
authorities below tab 8 page 172
and
approved by
lord bingham in a case called ask for
authorities below
tab 12
page 351
paragraph 15.
now my client the fifth appellant
he is a torture victim
as accepted by the secretary of state
he came under the control of an agent
and
we say that there is absolutely a case
in those circumstances that he doesn't
forfeit the protection of the article it
is not clear how long he spent
in intermediate states
on route
and there is a court of authority you
don't have it
to the effect that where an individual
asylum seeker is
under the control of an agent
then
an indirect flight will not be held
against them
that's ground four ground seven
the judge erroneously held that that
contributed nothing quote unquote
to the serious issue question
because
the fifth appellant was joined
as a party
as claimant 10 below c paragraph do you
have the judge's order my voice yes
paragraph one of the judge's order
and the secretary committed to take a
decision on his case
by noon today
flights tomorrow
and um he
uh as i
indicated to you
um
has been accepted to be
to have suffered torture
and that's it
this bundle page 444
that's the post-issue
bundle
page
but why was the judge wrong to say that
ground seven fell away because it
concerned two other claimants who
were no longer alive before him yes but
but what happened is that four claimants
were substituted in
on the morning of the hearing
and
certainly
i can't remember if it was all of them
but certainly
my clients
had the point that the secretary of
state
in
deciding that his case was
suitable for inadmissibility and rule to
rwanda
had failed to consider
his significant vulnerability
as disclosed
by the secretary's own acceptance
that he was into torture and you see
that
from
pages 448 to 449
that's the inadmissibility decision
you don't see anything interesting in
there i'm giving you the reference to
show you a negative there's nothing
there that engages with the fact that he
is
evicting torture
and nor do the removal direction at four
five four
and
the
i i'm grateful to mr pogba
that there is a document which makes it
clear that in to answer my law justice
singh's question is document our
amendment application made it clear
that
the fifth appellant
adopted
all of the grounds of challenge and
further submitted
that his removal decision was unlawful
for failure to consider his rule 35
report and that is it entering
pib post-issue
bundle 185 i'm grateful for mr portrait
sorry 185 185 paragraph 24
so that was squarely in play it wasn't
just that i did it orally we had it
i'm grateful to my juniors that they had
produced
a document which made it clear
that they that my client the fifth
appellant
was
adopting
ground seven
and we respectfully submit that the
judge was
wrong
plainly wrong
as a matter of legal assessment just
wrong to say quote unquote it
contributed nothing unfortunately you
don't have
the
[Music]
the corbon permission on the below
that contains the standard operating
procedure which selects people
for removal
but may i please just give you the
reference
the reference is
462
and that says that when you're looking
at people who are suitable for
relocation
one of the factors that you apply is
that
the individual has no quote unquote no
significant vulnerabilities or
safeguarding concerns
meets the priority criteria for onward
detention now mr hussain two two points
very quickly because i know you've got
very limited time here
um first of all can somebody on your
team please email us
the the core bundle because we'll get it
even while we're here we just have to
think about
secondly just remind me what is
the decision that the secretary of state
has said
she will take by midday today in respect
of this episode whether or not to take
him off the roster
tomorrow
so those are my submissions on ground
one
we say
the judge heard
in
his assessment of the legal strength
of our case where in respect of ground
one we say it was unanswerable
and was effectively conceded by the
secretary of state with
the apologies
effectively
don't say formally i don't say
completely good we understand that point
then once that's factored in my lord
sorry no no
i'm just keeping an eye on the clock
because you've got half an hour to meet
your other two
once that factors in that materially
shifts the balance of convenience i'm
going to move on to that now
the task of course lord walker in the
congo case is to minimize the risk of an
unjust result
that's the congo case supplementary
authorities
tab 2
page 20 at paragraph 39
and the first thing
to note
is
the act of removal what does that entail
leaving aside my submissions
on the strength of our case
removal involves detention on executive
warrant
forcible transfer
from the jurisdiction
just before you move away from detention
if this person let's take the fifth
appellant as an example
if he were not to be removed
to rwanda
tomorrow
on your submission would there be any
basis for detaining him
there absolutely would not
it is the operative reason and we see
that
from page four four five
of the five four four five which bundle
of the post issue the pib
where it is accepted
that he is
a torture victim
but the adults at risk
policy is applied
is regarded as an adult at risk but
because
removal is imminent
he's detained
and you see that from the
pre-penultimate paragraph
on page four four five
paragraphs starting should your asylum
claim
no that that's that's the penultimate i
meant the anti-penultimate anticipate a
primary consideration yes okay
all right so that's detention
detection yeah forcible removal from the
jurisdiction to a state
where the individual doesn't wish to go
whose protection they don't wish to seek
in circumstances where my lords my lady
these
persons
are exercising a legal right
and removal is intended to deter
others
now we respectfully submit that on any
view that is a
serious interference
with dignity
a4 shuuori
where asylum seekers
must be seen
in the words of the grand chamber in mss
as a particularly underprivileged and
vulnerable population group in need of
special protection
that's mss supplementary
authorities 3
page 72
paragraph 251
and if i can be forgiven
for
reminding you of the words of if i may
say so the great lord stain
nor justice staying in abdi and galway
where he said almost 30 years ago
a lot of refugees is often a desperate
one the specter of torture or death or
both often haunt them the amnesty
international reports graphically
document the scale of inhumanity of man
to man
that is why it is right to treat the
rights of asylum seekers as fundamental
rights
in a european democracy founded on
values of liberty and humanity such as
ours our law accords special protection
to such fundamental rights
everybody should know this
just give me the reference to mss and
again mss supplementary 3
page 72
paragraph 251
particularly vulnerable
population group special protection
needs and they go on to say
international european consensus about
that
grand
chamber
and then my lords if you then factor in
the judge we say
was plainly wrong
in describing in his judgment
this
sequence of events
as arduous
the word
everybody on this side of the room is
very clear that he used when he handed
down judgment was the word owner onerous
i'm not going to take a point
on
whether it's onerous or arduous
it is a manifestly inadequate
description of the serious other events
i've described
in the legal context
that they arise
and then
my lords my lady once one factors in the
strength of the case
then one is looking at
claims in tort
or damages claims under the human rights
act for damages one is looking at the
cost of bring back orders
or m orders as they used to be called
from the seminal case
why would there be a claim for
compensation if in the meantime
people have been acting according to
apparently lawful authority
oh because the uh uh this is
an interesting question which upon which
the supreme court ruled recently the
case called
gm rwanda
and it rests on the orthodox theory of
ultraviolence which is an executive
aspect of the virus is void administered
and incapable of having
is this really an application of lumbar
it's an applicable exactly model it's
application of lumbar
but this temporal issue arose in a case
called dn rwanda decided i think about
two years ago
where where uh lord kerr for the
majority held
uh that an executive orthodox view
um
i think he doubted firstly but that will
just assume the person in principle um
certainly an argument but but as regards
the tort of false imprisonment once you
vitiate the legal authority that has on
ordinary principles retroactive effect
so that's why you would have
a cast iron case
enforcement but i think you also make
the submission in your skeleton
certainly that leaving aside issues of
legal
remedies
you say this is a serious interference
with human dignity to detain someone and
to force them onto a plane and to force
them to go to another country if they do
not concern to do so
and that was the first
uh
submission i made under that head and
then
once you factor in
the legal strength of the case yes then
it becomes even more
stock
and once you factor in the cost of
emeralds
which may or may not be effective
and then
my lord's my lady
we say the judge heard
in
his approach to whether or not there was
a real risk of reform
on return this would be just
dispositive and the the key authority is
fb afghanistan
and you have that supplementary
volume supplementary tab 12
page 368.
well justin hickenbottom
at one one four
paragraph one one four sorry did i say
paragraph 114
where he essentially says that unless
you can summarily dismiss
a case
that there is a real risk
of after two article 3 after 33
treatment then the injunction should be
granted and here we're only concerned
with the short period until july
yes and the substantive case can be yeah
well we you make points about appeals
etc
my lady yes
but but this is this is a subset
of round one round one is about the
legal process
reformer doesn't exhaust legality
we have an unanswerable case and the
secretary hasn't begun to answer the
case on ground one that his that her
decision-making processes were
fundamentally flawed she was saying that
the unhcr's position was one of
pretty energetic and consistent support
nothing could have been further from the
truth
we do understand that so this is a
subset
and and
it would be dispositive of the balance
of convenience
so the question is is is there an
arguable case of a real risk
that's what happens in strasbourg for
example in rule 39 cases where you get
rule 39 measures not on demonstration of
a real risk itself because that's that's
the wrong
in this context it's it's significant
that the wrong is complete
on demonstration of a real risk and
there's a deep reason for that which is
that certain wrongs are so serious it's
not enough simply to prohibit them
you've got to be
take a preventative approach
in the words of lord winger to forestall
their occurrence
that's the a number two case where he
cites from the icty in for india but the
wrong is complete on demonstration of a
risk so it's not just the question is
is there gonna be a real risk
it's enough if i've got an arguable case
to that effect
and the secretary of state if inter
effectively accepts that
in her path
and i'll just give you the reference six
five five
paragraph 50
50 50.
and
we say
that
the uhcr's evidence on this point
felt was clear it felt to be accepted
expert body
uh expertise accepted by the secretary
of state below
i'll come on to the mou in a minute six
five five which bundle
uh the inter interim relief one right
and we we've explained in in our
skeleton or sought to do so
at footnote 8 and your hcr
make their submissions at paragraph 4
about why
their views are so important and in
public law terms it's because with
public law enlarging
analogizing the approach in public law
to questions of investment and weight
to the executive or public bodies
uhcr has constitutional responsibility
for refugees under the un general
assembly resolutions and article 35 of
the refugee convention and it has
institutional expertise it's on the
ground in kigali
from
1993. it's the the
uh
paramount
expert body and if you're going to
reject what they're saying you need at
the very minimum to give reasons mr
binsky's submissions
cite
how important the grand chamber
found unhcr's request to belgium
to stay removal of asylum sacred seekers
to greece the the grand chamber said
this was something of quote unquote
critical importance that is in the case
of an intra-eu transfer
the judge said that he had no time to
scrutinize
this evidence
we respectfully submit
that that was an erroneous approach
paragraph 23 we say
his task was to
do the best he could with great respect
to him but in so far as
he didn't have very much time to
scrutinize the evidence
that was because
of the secret state's serial default
with regard to disclosure
it wasn't our fault that a critical
minute of a meeting appeared at two
o'clock on friday
and then uh at mou and look verbal
we say
that that wasn't an answer
the judge held it paragraph 38
that it was realistic to suppose
that the mou would be complied with
but that's the wrong standard because
that's compatible
with a realistic prospect of reform
you've got to be sure that it would be
complied with
and applying the test the authority for
saying that you have to be sure it's
first principle because
if the issue is will there be a real
risk
you've got to have a system in place
which eradicates some real risk if the
system in place is simply realistic
well
don't we always have to bear in mind
that
the substantive merits of the judiciary
of claim have not yet
come before the court
so the judge was dealing
on a very urgent basis
with an application for interim relief
i i see the force of of of my lord's
point um
i think our submission would be that
because of the
paramount position of the uhcr if you're
going to
um
reject a careful and detailed and
evidenced
and explained submission
that there is a risk you've got to
explain yourself even on an interim
relief base
and one of these
interim relief applications
do go off as it were i can use the
vernacular
on demonstration of an arguable case of
real risk that's what justice in bottom
says
and yes this was a very urgent matter
but the material was there
the judge said he couldn't scrutinize it
properly he failed to take into account
why that was
um
we say the mou in the and the note
weren't an answer
because essentially applying the test
from the deportation with assurances
context
there was no quote unquote objective
basis
to believe that the assurances would be
fulfilled
and
the fulfillment wasn't capable of being
verified and we see that
that that's taken from the case of bb in
the court of appeal
supplementary authorities three
uh pages 215 to two tab
three seven
seven tab seven yep
page uh 215 to 216.
paragraph 27.
that thing's about that case is that is
that one eye
i wasn't sure possibly one of the few
ones
but
the mou
is not enforceable
not enforceable by whom
in law
but the uk can influence even the uk
doesn't give rise to any legal rights
not even the uk
but in international relations this is
frequently the case and states
expect each other to comply expectation
yeah yeah
there can be diplomatic consequences for
example i i accept that i'm simply
making a narrow point and unhcr say i
don't know if you recall the passage i
think it's in paragraph 11 in their
analysis that if you're going to do
something this dramatic it's got to be
by reference to a a legal regime which
gives rise to legal rights and
obligations
not
particularly by the way of expectation
that's their position but it's relevant
i'm not saying it's dispositive at all
i'm not saying that they can't do it i'm
saying it's relevant to looking at
whether or not it eradicates what we say
otherwise there clearly is a risk of
of the formula
um the reference is uh paragraph 1.6
interim relief 16135
it doesn't give rise to legal rights
paragraph 2.2
again page 135
uh mr pogba helps me 1.6 yes i have the
preference the arrangement will not be
finding an international law page number
sorry one one three five yeah paragraph
1.6
um
the note the vowel
wasn't published
i said earlier it wasn't published with
the mou despite the fact it was signed
at the same time the 13th of april
secretary state said this was because it
didn't contain the policy
there is no requirement to publish it
that's interim relief
665
despite the fact that there is very
heavy reliance on the merkle ball
before this court and below
and i made the point the publication was
important to commit
scrutiny
and the case is nasir
36.
um the mou we say
there's no objective basis for thinking
it will deliver
because the flaws in the system
are systemic and they require in your
hcr's words long-term and fundamental
engagement by taking you to that passage
it's a pib 23-24
and then verification my lord my lady
that's not possible because the
monitoring mechanism isn't set up
yet
the mou is predicated on interim on
independent
monitoring with terms of reference to
include
how
the group
will monitor the entire
the entire relocation process that's
interim relief 1514
para15
and a joint committee
is to be set up
under
paragraph
21
to ensure
that the monitoring committee has
unfatted access
to locations
officials
and records
and the verbal
also contemplates
such a monitoring committee paragraph 11
that's irb
2
7
we respectfully submit that future
actions that might be taken to implement
monitoring under the mou which is an
essential premise
of the undertaking cannot govern cannot
have any bearing i should say
on current balance of convenience issues
the mou is also predicated
on there being a functioning system the
rwandan government and it seems the uk
believe
that their the function is
operating and that's i showed you the
reference right at the beginning of my
submissions to the general assessment at
page one
five three
where the secretary of state says
a functioning asylum process is in
operation
in rwanda so that's the premise of the
mou
so
everything is more or less okay here
we'll have some more
promises
but everything isn't okay at all as we
see from uhcr
and in fact i'm just going to take you
back to the minute that's also
the strategy state's own
private position
because can i if i can just take you
back to
pib
the minutes exhibited
to
mr hobbs
page 77
so i took you to this very important
minute
earlier
i showed you the first half of the page
but then if you look at the comment
so this is the secretary state's
official does my lord have it
it's a pib 77
this is the 26th of april exactly yes i
have it yeah where are you looking at
now uh at the bottom of 77. yes thank
you
and if you see the comment there so this
is a structure states official
it was useful to hear from those on the
ground
although
although clearly these differ markedly
from the gor perspective
and that's very significant for the
reason i just gave you that the mou on
the rwandan government side seems to be
promised on the idea that there is a
functioning system in fact that's also
the social states view the public view
new state's public view on the 19th of
may is that there is a functioning
system
in her private view is the issues raised
are ones we will want clear assurances
on
they haven't had any
this minute
the meeting was 25th
11 days after
sorry twelve days after
the mou and the end not verbal were
signed
there have been no more assurances
and if my lord's going to ask me did i
make exactly the submission almost
verbatim
and you say that not because you know
they haven't but because they haven't
produced that oh yes because there's no
evidence of it
one would have thought that that is
something the secretary would have
disclosed
so so the the
sorry
where was that the issues racing once we
want clear assurances on
and or will need to be carefully
monitored well there's no monitoring
the group hasn't been set up
over the course of the partnership
perhaps we could add these to i think
that's the home office lawyers
association something
it's a legal branch of almost nothing
says that's right list of assurances if
they're not already there is that home
office legal advice exactly
we tried to assuage their concerns where
possible but acknowledged where their
questions were more for the g.o.r to
answer
yes where are the answers there aren't
any mr said i don't want to interrupt
you at all
but you've got about five minutes you're
on ground two at the moment
my daughter yes
i think the only other thing i was going
to say about the mou
was that
um
the approach
from the deportation
with assurances
has to be applied with caution because
in that context typically there's an
agreed problem there's an agreed
solution and the assurance is given
specific to an individual or a class
here
the problem isn't agreed the solution
isn't agreed and the assurances are in
kuwait and system wide
uh and then uh
my lord my ladies
the sixth week point we say that's not
an answer because
the judge was wrong to confine
his analysis
to the period when the high court would
give a judgment he had no regard to the
risk that a person might remain in
rwanda beyond an initial judgment from
the court what if the bring back order
wasn't possible there is an article in
the emoji which says
that that
best endeavors would be used by the
rwandans if the social state was under
an obligation but that's that's the best
endeavor's duty
what if the individuals is undocumented
detained disappears
and then also it doesn't account for the
scale of the problem
in in the system
individual could be processed
the timing it can go quite quickly i'll
just give you two references interim
relief one seven six and one eight five
public interest
there are five points
public interest one
the policy is expressed to deter
dangerous journeys and deter gangs
mr dunlop's skeleton with respect to him
talks about unnecessary and illegal
journeys
that is not an accurate description
because
in the present state of our law it has
never been
a criminal offence or illegal
to arrive in the uk
as opposed to enter to arrive in the uk
without relevant documentation my laws
my lady will know
it is impossible
to get refugee visas from war so our law
um
at present
does not render criminal
the act of arriving
without documentation indeed the refugee
convention has always contemplated it
there were dramatic events in the 1930s
when you had an authorization model
250 jewish refugees died
because the canadians the cubans in the
u.s turned away the s saint louis in
1938
i think at this juncture i probably
should interrupt you in your own
interests because you've got about two
minutes and you haven't even got to
ground three yet i i'm going to be very
quick i mean yeah and obviously we've
read things in writing in particular
your skeleton so we have the points yes
we have the grounds of appeal so so i
i'm just going to
very quickly shoot through update
four points on public interest
numbers
that's relevant only 11.
it's policy not legislation
it's an mou rather than a treat if it
was a treaty you would have had
parliamentary scrutiny
um the timeline
doesn't indicate urgency
the meetings commenced in january 2022
the mou and the ball were signed
and the plan announced in april 2022
the assessments were published in may
and the delay of if it's six weeks
that goes in favor of us we respectfully
submit and we the last point i want to
make is there's no evidence of
deterrence
on ground three
very quickly
the judge was wrong to say there was a
mismatch between the relief sort
and the ground and the matter of the
matters challenge
cpr part 34 part 54 doesn't say
enactment
decision but not a policy
one can challenge policies we were
challenging the policy the underlying
policy which your lordships and
leadership have seen
governs what happens in individual cases
it doesn't dictate it but
governs it
so we're challenging both
and if these my submissions are good
then they apply across the board
we've given you the references to why
there is jurisdiction and it's
appropriate in certain circumstances to
make a general relief order
um
either you can do it by granting relief
the obvious way to do it is to grant
relief for the fifth appellant and then
because he is in the same circumstances
as of as of the other 10
rather than
requiring the other 10 to be fortunate
enough to get legal
assistance and move the court in the
next 24 hours the justice
of the situation
indicates
that a general order should be made
the general order you're envisaging in
that submission
relates only to tomorrow's flight
yeah we want to but but um
i just want to be clear
you're not asking whatever view we take
and i and i want to make it clear we
have no
view about how this case will be decided
but whatever view we take at the end of
the day you are not asking us to make a
generic order which could stop any
person being removed without their
consent
pending the high court substantive
hearing
we we
is that right you're right we try to be
very careful and keep the interim relief
as narrow as possible
that's very helpful though yeah that's
right that's that's that's can i just
check if my lady
has any questions you know we're very
grateful to you mr saying
we're very grateful to you thank you
very much thank you very much yes
my lords are my lady unhcr is very
grateful for the courts wanting
permission to intervene and and for the
principal party's agreement to this
unhcr has conveyed warnings over the
illegality and risks of the uk rwanda
arrangement with escalating urgency
specificity and force
directly to the secretary of state and
also of course to the courts in
litigation to which the secretary of
state is party can i just set out for
steps
so on the 8th of june
unhcr centered a secretary of state the
document which we referred to i think mr
hussein is referred to i believe as a
legal analysis document and we've used
the same terminology
and mr hussein has taken you to that
and this document explains unhcr's view
that the uk rwanda arrangement is
unlawful
and that it contains inadequate
safeguards to guarantee international
protection
then
unhcr's view that there is a real risk
of indirect reform
in the event that tomorrow's flight
proceeds
was relayed
in terms to mr justice swift at friday's
hearing
along with a clear warning that this
real risk arose even in the short time
anticipated
before the full hearing in july and i
shall return later to the timing point
for me
thus
by the time of the hearing reformist
suggested swift
unhcr had warned that the uk rwanda
arrangement was unlawful
and that there was a real risk of
indirect informal if people were removed
under it
then unhcr made explicit
what was already obvious
and stated its position that tomorrow's
flight must be stopped
and may i just draw your attention to
paragraphs seven and eight
of the um
unhcr's uh written submission for
today's hearing
and may i emphasize it this is language
of course carefully selected and
approved by unhcr unhcr's unequivocal
position
is that the flight on 14th of june to
rwanda should not proceed
and more generally removals to rwanda
under the uk rwanda agreement should be
suspended and may i say of course it
went when i used the imperative earlier
that's really unhcr's position towards
the secretary of state and not of course
with great respect towards this court um
although we certainly
urge upon the court that result
uh i have four four points today
the first concerns the judges approach
to unhcr's evidence
the second concerns the secretary of
state's argument but in effect unhcr's
evidence can be discounted in any event
our third point concerns the
aspirational nature of the novel
and the impossibility of achieving those
aspirations in rwanda in the short term
given the deep structural deficiencies
in rwanda's asylum system and our fourth
point concerns timing the six-week
interim period
and turning to our first point the the
approach of the charge um
it's axiomatic the great respect is owed
to unhcr's assessment of factual matters
within its remits uh mr hussein has
already taken you to to the authorities
and i don't propose to you to repeat
those
the only evidence about rwandan capacity
and the refugee status determination
process apparently evaluated by mr
justice swift and his judgment was that
of unhcr
the only evidence about reform from
rwanda apparently evaluated by mr
justice swift and his judgment was again
unhcr although he would with great
respect say that his treatment of
unhcr's evidence was cursory
so
what did mr justice swift make of unhcr
evidence it's actually difficult to tell
at paragraph 24 mr justice swift found a
serious tribal issue at ground one and
did so apparently at least in part in
reliance upon information provided by
unhc on the 9th of june
then at paragraph 36 he considered the
mou a notebook value to be
countervailing factors
although i shall come back in a moment
to the point that those were not of
course evidence of capacity nor evidence
that indirect with fulmont was not
taking place
at paragraph 41 mr justice swift then
said he was not able at this stage in
proceedings to scrutinize the evidence
of unhcr because that had arrived on the
9th of june he said this was not a
criticism rather to make clear the speed
with which matters in the claim had
developed
then he stated at parable 43 that there
was no realistic risk but the claimants
would be at real risk of
of ill treatment or reform
um so we do say there are two ways of
interpreting mr justice swift's
conclusions
on the first
uh
he did not scrutinize unhcr's evidence
of the 9th of june because it arrived
shortly before the hearing
um
and we say
if he failed to treat the arrival of
evidence from a body of as it's been
called by the supreme court matchless
experience and expertise as reason to
pause in a case causing the risk of
referral harm and that is the antithesis
of anxious scrutiny
on the other analysis
mr justice swift would have found uh
that there was a serious issue to be
tried but then
without
any or certainly any cogent reasons and
without assessing countervailing
evidence went on to dismiss the same
evidence as inadequate and we do say on
either approach that was plainly wrong
and but we do say also that the respect
of unhcr
is
greater than
that that we owed for example to just
simply to an authoritative expert and
particularly so in this context we say
that where as here unhcr warns
unequivocally but a certain policy or
practice uh
or removal to a particular destination
will breach a signatory states uh
obligations under the refugee convention
that is critically important uh and that
was in effect at the approach of the
grand chamber and mss you've already
been referred to that i won't repeat the
point
turning now to the second point and i
can take this very briefly
mr dunlop's uh submission
on unhcr's evidence is essentially to
suggest that unhcr has changed its
position
the july 2020 document to which mr
dunlop refers
was drafted at a time that the
overwhelming majority of refugee
determinations were prima facie in
rwanda and in fact at unhr
in respect of the nascent
individualized system very serious
concerns in that july 2020 document the
second point made by mr dunlop
about unhcr's evidence is that there is
an implied suggestion that unhcr's views
can be discounted because unhcr did not
see the not verbal until the 10th of
june
but the reason of course that we didn't
see them because we weren't given them
despite requesting them
unhcr has had time in fact we did we did
also make observations performance
adjusters swift on them we've had
further time now to consider them um
and i'm turning now to part three of my
submission and in order to make this at
speed i hope i'll be forgiven for
handing up a table so that i don't have
to
skip around on
evidence
does mr dunlop have this i'm just
handing it i'm trying to do both at the
same time yes
and
the
point that we make here
is that unhcr has consistently
in evidence before the court over
in some cases since july 2020 raised
serious concerns for the structural
defects that cannot be rectified by the
purely aspirational albeit laudable
statements of intent as to the future
in the not verbal
so
just to take three points in here
train decision makers
there are on the first page you'll see
serious concerns raised about a lack of
training a lack of qualification among
decision makers if you look at the
second citation unhcr at the last line
has repeatedly offered training but only
once has that been taken up and for
three days in late 2021
turning
next to impartiality
a concern a concern again about the
structure for example that the same
body sits on the internal appeal the
paper appeal at the rsdc
as sits
at first instance
turning next to legal advice
there's the question of lawyers and
unhcr
has
funds 21 lawyers in rwanda
but of those
only one is competent and experienced
and trained to do rsd determinations
and and it's our understanding that that
is the only person in rwanda
who has been trained by unhcr who's
currently available to work on rsd
determinations one lawyer
and turning to interpreters where again
there is a guarantee of provision of
interpreters unhcr is particularly well
placed to to comment again here because
what the rwandan government does is
essentially borrow interpreters from a
unhcr that unhcr is using for a separate
purpose which is its emergency transit
mechanism running camps for people
evacuated from libya so unhcr
sometimes lends interpreters but knows
that there is a limited pool and a still
more limited number of languages that
these speak
so i i i won't go further through that
but it's to make the
and i can assure you that we will read
it with care i i'm most grateful
um
so the nod
set out no practical steps to achieve to
achieve their reigns but even if they
did
they could not possibly by the very
nature of these structural defects be
rectified in a short period still less
by tomorrow and if i may add something
and i need to say we didn't make this
point before mr justice swift because we
only assumed that val in the course of a
hearing and had to take instructions
afterwards but unhcr is aware of no
steps
currently being taken in rwanda
to rectify these deficiencies as to
training as to interpreters as lawyers
i i turn now if i may to the issue of
timing um unhcr shares the the appellant
skepticism about the six week period and
i'll check to ask you one very quick
question absolutely that last submission
about being aware of no steps being
taken directly do you say that goes to
the claimant's ground one or the balance
of convenience or what
both lord both my lord so it's it's
prejudice and balance of convenience yes
um
turning to to uh
the timing issue which is our last point
um mr justice swift at paragraph 43 of
his judgment for the purposes of
assessing prejudice
looked at the interim period
which he considered to be a six week
period and we share the skepticism about
this the six week period but
we won't repeat that point but
mr justice swift's reached his
conclusion on the basis that um who were
then claimants nine and ten would have
their claims
uh determined dismissed and removed in
circums in circumstance amounting with
full month was only a very small risk
but unhcr points out that is not the
only form the indirect reformer can take
you can have preemptory reform on and
unhcr's evidence uh contains specific
instances of people prevented from
making their claims so there's uh two
libyans referred to in the march 22
kigali interview
then
in uh the april 25 uh kigali further
interview that was only disclosed by uh
the respondent at our urging on the 10th
of june uh there's reference to a
further three people being the fault mr
dunlop cast doubt on whether that was in
case in a case of the four month briefly
unhcr has provided a gist of its notes
of the meeting which are consistent with
the the respondents but made clear that
these are instances of people being
pushed back at the airport back onto
flight this is reformant
just on that point isn't uh
wasn't the view of the judge that in
circumstances where this scheme
was designed to enable refugee status
determinations
that that was very unlikely to occur in
light of the mou
and the mvs
my lady
quite so and that's why i'd like to come
on to the further form that before mark
can take and and we've named it
constructive before one but it may
actually to avoid any confusion as to
any
requirement of intent really what this
is is de facto reform on
de facto indirect reform on where no
decision is taken that life is made so
impossible intentionally or not that
people leave
and
this is not a fanciful prospect unhcr
has seen this happening and it's seen it
happening under the precedent to the is
to the uk rwanda
agreement that was the israel rwanda
arrangement
and that is i'll just give you the
citation it's
a
pib i'm sorry
trying to read my own writing i think
it's top page 26 but it's
near it's at the end of the analysis
document where unh i explained this has
happened before considerable numbers
undertook dangerous journeys to leave
rwanda
and
go to africa and europe and in response
to my lord's question was that also goes
to balance of convenience because if the
idea is to deter dangerous journeys
unhci is saying this actually risks
generating dangerous journeys including
back to the uk
um
and and and in terms of people
doing this in terms of people simply
giving up in desperation
this is intertwined with the problem of
capacity so mr justice swift effectively
segregated the problem capacity which he
saw as going to the long term problem
and then the short-term issues which you
saw it's entirely separate
but they're intertwined so if somebody
arrives for example who is albanian
taking three nationalities we believe to
be on the flight uh uh uh albanian uh uh
i beg your pardon trying to find the
note albanian vietnamese
and iranian
they arrive
nobody to interpret at their screening
interview
a decision is taken can't be translated
to them
possibly their cases then refer to the
next level
can't make submissions can't find a
lawyer if they can find a lawyer can't
talk to the lawyer so this is a futile
absurd hopeless
process
and it is
entirely foreseeable that people in
those circumstances who have no prospect
of establishing their entitlement to
refugee status no prospect of a durable
solution no prospect of leaving limbo
will move on
mr winsky
you're slightly over the allotted time
my lord may make one final point if i if
i may
which is the unhcr
putting aside the other two points on
timing is very concerned by the
proposition that injunctive relief
should be denied to people
and that people should be essentially
transported across the world
on the basis that they argue it arguably
would be at real risk of effortable harm
at a later date
but could be returned in time
and we do say that that ignores the
human cost of displacement
that it gambles casually with lives and
safety what if somebody is not located
as a as my learner from mr hussein says
and and
unhcr with the moral authority as well
as expertise and experience that it
brings
is highly concerned by this
experimental
approach
and with the disregard but that entails
for the dignity and humanity of those
involved
thank you very much
thank you my lords and my lady can i
make my submissions by reference to our
skeleton argument please if you have
that
uh can i begin at um paragraph 12 of
that skeleton argument
yes
um here we
well
set out general principles
and although there are no apparent
differences between my learned friends
and i on that
much of my learned friends submissions
are in substance about the weights to be
given to relevant factors
and
as a result it's helpful to
remember
the approach taken
consistently but in particular in the
case of yz china
which we have cited there
given the short time i have unless you
wish me to i won't take you to that
judgment
but um for your reference it's page 179
of the supplementary authorities bundle
and it provides a good approach
so a good example of the correct
approach to appeals of this kind
and it's telling that in that case the
court repeal judge said
of a particular point that's not a point
on which i would have placed much weight
but it did not lead to allowing the
appeal because weight to be given to
relevant factors in a discretionary
decision such as this is not something
that found a successful appeal
so that's the general approach and move
on to ground one
ground one can be split into two
sub-issues
the first is disagreement with the
judge's assessments
of the prospects on jr ground one
and the second is disagreements with the
judge's assessments of other grounds
such as four six and seven
our skeleton at paragraph 13 to 14
deals with
that first sub-category
criticisms of the judge's assessments
of the prospects of jr ground one
the points we make in paragraph 13 to 14
can be distilled down to two points
which i'll expand on
the first point
is that if and in so far is the
submission is
that jr ground one is bound to succeed
then the judge was entitled to disagree
to find it wasn't bound to succeed
that's the first point which i'll expand
on
the second point is that
if and in so far as the submission is
that the judge
should have put the merits a bit higher
described them as compelling rather than
a serious issue
then that cannot found
a successful appeal
so
if i start with
the first point
bound to succeed
can i first address a point that was
made orally
today but i didn't
foresee from the skeleton argument and
that is the alleged concession
by
um
the witness for the secretary of state
mr hobbs
and can i take you to what he actually
said
it's at page 76
of the pib as i've been calling it the
post
issue bundle
yes
paragraph 8 on page 76 is what he
actually said
what he said was concerns with certain
letters
sent to those of removal directions for
the 14 june flights were brought to my
attention
investigations were made and confirmed
errors were made in seven letters
responding to human rights claims that
mischaracterized the role of unhcr
i can confirm this was an error
resulting from this reading of the cpit
report
so you might have thought that point to
my own friend's submissions that these
errors
reached across every single removal
decision that is not correct
and indeed
the fifth appellant the only live
appellant
has not received a letter with these
errors
so whatever kind of concession
you might call this
it is not a concession
that ground one is bound to succeed for
every single removal
and
just to clarify in relation to the only
existing individual apparent
a5
my understanding i wasn't there on
friday my understanding is the secretary
say undertook not just to say whether
removal directions
would be cancelled but to provide a
supplementary decision letter on in
municipality
and certification or certainly on
admissibility but i'm not sure whether
certification was mentioned
and i understand from instruction that
is still the aim to do that by noon
today
okay can i just ask you mr donald if
you're moving on to another point yes
can i just put this in the context
of the proceedings
which are currently before the high
court
if i understand it the claim began
in the middle of last week
yes i think
obviously because of the urgency of the
situation
this hasn't followed the normal course
where for example
there would be
some time for summary grounds of
resistance to be filed
and a judge would consider the
application information on the papers
yes
still less as i understand it has there
yet been evidence filed by the secretary
of state beyond what we've seen
obviously but yes i imagine that
the directions is this right for the
rolled up hearing in july
quantum play the secretary of state will
have the opportunity to file detailed
evidence absolutely they do and an order
was agreed this morning and this is a
point i was going to come back to again
and again a lot of the issues where
learned friends raise underground ones
and ones that can only really be
assessed once the secretary has had that
opportunity to file evidence
i mean this is not a unique
situation
which courts find themselves in
in public law proceedings
it is not infrequently the case in
private law proceedings
and other types of proceedings that
there is to be
a trial
and here it's been expedited
but nevertheless even with expedition it
inevitably takes some time
for a trial to take place
and
it may well be
that
there will be factual issues which have
to be determined at the trial but
presumably the court will then be in a
position to determine those factual
issues on the basis of the fullest
possible evidence
and indeed
we'll have more time
to use the word i think that's being
used in the context of the unhcr to
scrutinize
the evidence
but
i mean
i agree with everything you've just said
at the nodding but for the sake of this
kind of strip i agree with all of it but
does it does it follow that if
something is being placed before the
court as a matter of urgency for
entirely understandable reasons and
without any criticism of anyone
a judge may find himself with very
limited opportunity
to consider the evidence it is in any
event unlikely to be the full evidence
what on your submission what is the
judge supposed to do in that situation
well my institution what the judge is
supposed to do is exactly what he did
form a view on whether there's a serious
issue to be tried and then examine the
balance of convenience
what he
could not do
was entitled not to do
was say well this is bound to succeed i
haven't even seen the secretary's
evidence but it's bound to succeed
um
my lord
the essence of it
these issues that are raised under
ground one
are ones which will turn on evidence
they are concerns
principally structural concerns about
the rwandan
refugee status determination process
and um about whether the assurances in
the mou and nuclear bile
will in practice be met
that is something that's going to turn
on evidence
on the secretary of state's evidence
as to why she has reason to believe
that the assurances
in the note verbal
and the mou will be met
and so for example
my learned friend mr binsky for the
unhcr
raised a new point which she very fairly
and properly pointed out she hadn't
raised before the judge about not being
aware of things happening on the ground
now
well that is a point on which the
secretary of state will want to respond
with evidence when it needs to be
determined
certainly don't accept that nothing's
happening on the ground
it's not now the time or place to submit
evidence about what is happening on the
ground
that is
evidence that will be produced for the
substantive hearing
so my lords and my lady i can go through
the um
uh paragraph 18 of the unhcr's june
assessment
and i can
foreshadow the kinds of response the
kinds of evidence the secretary of state
will give to those structural concerns
but
i don't know if that's helpful to you in
the time i have
um well i think what we need to bear in
mind and and on all sides is that we are
not the court of first instance
we are the court of appeal
and we are being asked to upset the
discretionary decision
of mr justice swift
so it's a matter for you how you present
your positions
yes
um well um
i'm grateful for that indication um
what i'll do is then i'll move on if i
may and if i still have time left i
might come back to paragraph 18
and take you through the various ways
that that is met by the mou and the note
about
but just by way of example some of the
concerns are practical things like
interpreters lawyers and so on which
come which are met by the node for a
bowel and the question will be well
that's all very well but is there
evidence this is actually going to
happen
and that that is a massive for evidence
to do course
um
so um
i'll turn to the sort of second limb if
the case is
um
not that it's bound to succeed but
there's a sort of difference in nuance
uh a difference in the sort of
percentage prospects
um that was material between saying it
was a serious issue to be tried when in
fact he should have said it was a
compelling issue
well that
is not a ground of appeal because that
is
about the weight to be given to at most
it's about the weight
to be given to
a relevant factor the fact that the
claims might succeed
um we mentioned in our skeleton argument
the mother care case
we provided many days at paragraph 29
approving it my lonely friend says there
are other authorities that go against it
neither of that matters because that's
when one's looking at it at first
instance making a decision on interim
relief now that we've got to your stage
is this a classic example the sort of
issue
that was for the discretion of the trial
judge who listened to argument all day
long and gave his judgment at six
or whatever it was
um
and not something that this court can
realistically expect to second guess
well even if we could
i think you would submit
that's not actually the function of an
appellate court exactly i would submit
that
so um
i then move on to the submissions made
in relation to ground four
and
we've dealt with these at paragraphs 15
to 16 of our skeleton argument
and
in essence
there are
two points to be made the first is that
this doesn't matter
the judge said quite rightly
in his
uh judgment and it's paragraph 14 of his
note of the judgment
that the issue for him
at the first stage
was whether there were one or more and i
quote one or more serious tribal issues
and if there was
then relief depends on the balance of
convenience
it follows logically
that it just does not matter
whether one two three four or
five uh grounds of appeal that presented
serious issues to be tried
that's not what the decision on interim
relief turned on
and so even if my lone friend had
points to be made about ground four
they're not ones that should trouble you
they're ones that he can revive at the
substantive hearing
mr justice thing did not refuse
permission on any ground he merely gave
an indication and invited the claimants
to consider that indication
so it follows that if appellant five
um is still a claimant when it comes to
the final hearing in july he can make
his argument about why
um
there was um
in his case he came directly
notwithstanding the fact he passed
through many
uh safe third countries in the interim
um
and as for ground seven um
well the pleaded case
was against
uh the second and fourth payments
um for the reasons i've given it simply
doesn't matter whether ground seven was
also relevant to appellant five
um this is an issue that really
can only crystallize
as a new ground when a new decision is
taken in relation to opponent five the
whole point of the secretary of state's
agreement
to make a new decision was because she
accepted that she should have regard to
the rule 35 report
so
whether or not she does that adequately
is something that simply cannot be
assessed yet
certainly couldn't can you say that
again is that true it has accepted what
exactly well the reason i wasn't there
on friday but as i understand the
motivation
for the secretary of state saying that
she would make a further decision in
relation to a5
was because
a5 had a rule 35 report referring to
having been a victim of torture yeah and
the secretary of state said
that she would consider again
whether to maintain removal directions
and maintain the decision
that a5
asylum claim was inadmissible in light
of that fact
that is the the decision
which um is expected by 12 today
thank you very much
so um my lords and my lady i then move
on to paragraph
of our skeleton arguments
yes
this is on round two so we're now moving
on to ground two yes balance of
convenience
um and i've gone through the seven
alleged errors that were alleged in the
skeleton argument
uh the first adds nothing to ground one
the second
which was addressed at paragraph 19
has no merit it's essentially a
challenge to the factual assessment by
the judge on the evidence before him
yesterday that the risk of reformant or
sorry yesterday i should say friday the
risk of reformat or harm in the interim
period
before the end of july 2022 was no more
than speculative
and a ground like ground two could only
succeed if that assessment
was irrational or plainly wrong
it was not
the judge plainly carefully considered
the unhcr evidence he said he hadn't had
much time to scrutinize it and i
emphasized the word scrutinized that's
in the nature of an interim relief
application but he plainly considered it
we had there was a full day hearing
looking principally at that evidence
um and his view was that um
his assessment was that there was no
more than a speculative possibility of
any risk of reformat of any form or harm
in the interim period to july
2022. in that context um and please
don't
take anything out of order
but can i can you help us on one
particular point that has occurred to me
which is that as i read the unhcr
material
there is a specific concern they've
expressed about people from middle
eastern countries
and that
on one view i don't know if this is
accepted
that
those
applicants for asylum will
systematically be rejected
now if if that factual premise were
correct
then it's not implausible is it that
somebody might have their claim rejected
in the next few weeks
um
well my lord it's maine that may be
right as far as it goes
but one once what one is talking about
here is
um the possibility of refulment not just
an initial rejection of a claim in the
next six weeks
which is why it's important to consider
the
appropriate time scales that one is uh
talking about
and that the judge considered
there is a two-tier suspensive appeal
process
let me just take you to that it's at
um page 171
of the notes verbal sorry of the um
interim relief bundle it comes from the
note of a ball
so
171 of the interim relief bundle
let me just get that no 271 sorry 271
271
so um
i'm
picking up in the middle of the note for
about here at 271
um
perhaps i should just go back to the
beginning at 2 6 9.
so paragraph 3 access to asylum
process
a relocated individual will have the
opportunity to make an asylum claim
3.1.2 be informed of the procedure
dot dot in a language they understand
3.1.3 be informed of the procedure for
making a complaint about the processing
of their crime
and then section 4
is about
asylum decision making what might be
called
first instance decision making
and a 4.2 says that asylum decisions
will be taken by decision makers who are
appropriately trained
4.3
is about the opportunity the relocated
individuals have to present their case
and
it includes
the requirement for an interview
and 4.4 sets out the requirements of the
interview
you'll notice
4.4.2.3 has to be in the presence of an
interpreter
4.7
arrangements will be made to surely
decisions taken on individual claims are
recorded 4.8 relocated individuals will
be notified in writing
of the decision and 4.9
it will be translated into a language
they understand and 4.9.2 will include
the reasons for the decision
and these are all there to meet concerns
that have been raised about how
decisions didn't have reasons attached
to them
so um i think my then friend said at one
stage that the secretary state has
suggested unhr had said everything was
okay that has never been the secretary
of state's position the secretary of
state has listened and seriously
considered the concerns raised by the
nhr and has deliberately negotiated
arrangements to provide assurances in
relation to those concerns
and so this is an example of one of
those assurances
and um
the um
that that's the process for getting a
decision
you go to your decision with the reasons
and then we get section five to asylum
appeals
and um
there are two tiers of appeals i said
the first is
a an appeal
to the minister responsible
um
and at 5.2 you can see
that the
appellant has the opportunity to make
oral
and or written submissions
um
and it said um well that this is not
really an independent level of appeal
but
that
we say should not matter in light of 5.3
which is the second tier of appeal
which is that
um the relocated individual whose
appeals have been refused by the
minister can then be permitted to appeal
that decision to the high court
and 5.4
the court will be able to conduct a full
re-examination
of the relocated individuals paying in
fact and in law
in accordance with rules of court
procedure
and then 5.6 is the point i made about
it being suspensive
a relocated individual who is refused
asylum will not be removed from awanda
until they are out of time to bring an
appeal or if they choose to appeal the
decision the conclusion of their appeal
there's nothing about time limits there
your point was that none of this could
happen within the six-week period
there's nothing
there's nothing here there is another
document with indicative timelines i can
take you to in a moment and it's fair to
say that um although the unhcr says well
those are aspirational and action
practices takes much longer those
timelines will not produce a result of
the second tier within six weeks
there is also the fact that even once
one gets to the end of this process of
two tiers of suspensive appeal
the relocated individual has the
opportunity to apply for leave to remain
on other grounds
and you can see that from the um
memorandum of understanding
at page 138 of the same bundle
again this is something that the judge
has taken to and looked at
and i think he especially refers to in
his decision
if you turn to page 138 of the interim
relief bundle
that's the page with assurances as to
treatment
and then if you look at 10.3
10.1 is is the requirement to
decide whether they're refugees and
grant them refugee stasis if so 10.2 is
of the requirement to decide whether
they have another humanitarian
protection need
and 10.3 is what i wanted to take you to
for those relocated individuals who are
neither recognized as refugees nor to
have protection
need in accordance with paragraph 10.2
um
protection needs in accordance with
paragraph number two rwanda will
10.3.1
offer an opportunity for the relocated
individual to apply for permission to
remain in rwanda on any other basis
in accordance with its domestic
immigration laws
and ensure the relocated individual is
provided with the relevant information
needed to make such an application
and one last
uh document of the evidence before the
judge
that i referred to in my answer to the
question from my lady lady justice
simler
this is
page 176
of the same bundle
this is from one of the um c pitch
reports
and it records what
the secretary was told about timelines
so
4.3.1 sets out the timeline for key
stages in the process
submission of application files
within 15 days decision at first
instance within 45
days although can be made sooner
notification of the decision within 10
days appeal within 30 days appeal
decision within 30 days
and that's that's dealing as i
understand it with the um first instance
of the first tier of appeal but whether
or not i'm right about that the fact is
that overall
as the judge found when he looked at all
of this
there is no more than a speculative risk
that anyone going through these
processes
even if there is systematic bias against
certain countries is actually going to
be subject to a decision to remove to
that country in the six weeks before the
substantive period
it follows that
the judge was right was certainly
entitled to find that looking at the
balance of convenience
that this is
not these concerns of structural
problems
whether they be
systematic bias or they be lack of
interpreters lack of
lawyers they all can be dealt with in
the july hearing and no one is likely to
be removed or come to the end of the
process and subject to decision to
remove
before then
so um there's the other
uh concern which the unhcr has raised
which is about
um
sort of refusal
to let someone in in the first place
so um even at the time of the cpit
report there was an instance involving
two libyan individuals who were not
allowed to arrive in the airport weren't
allowed to leave the airport
and
um that was considered in the cpip
report
by the time of the 25th of april meeting
there have been
some three further examples of similar
sorts of situations my learner friend is
clarified individuals not allowed to
enter the territory
the judge was entitled to find
that those kinds of issues simply don't
arise on this arrangement
because the whole purpose
of the partnership and the mou
is
for rwanda to accept these individuals
into their country and consider their
asylum claims
and presumably if they was turned away
as it were at the door
they'd have to come back to united
kingdom that that's a fair point yeah i
would have thought but i haven't quite
turned my mind to that thought i'm quite
sure where else they would be going well
that's a fair point i hadn't thought
about that but yes i can't i don't see
the answer to that at the moment well
someone else makes sense
um
but the reality is that's just not going
to happen because
what happens in fact the secretary of
state says we'd like to remove these
individuals xyz here are their names
dates of birth here their countries they
come from
now if rwanda was going to say well
we're not going to deal with anyone from
this country they wouldn't accept them
in the first place the people who are
subject to the removal decisions
are the people they have accepted
and that's part of the mou
process that mystics agree to that yes
and
are you going to make submissions more
generally about the legal
status of the mou and np's i don't want
to take you out of order um
i don't think i can really add to the
points that you've made my lord
it's the reality is that an mou
can be a legitimate
source of assurance
for one country to
in relation to another country
it all depends on the evidence
it all depends on
the evidence
that in our case will likely be heard in
july
as to a whether they have the capacity
um and the funding and the resources to
live up to the the assurances and b
whether they have the the diplomatic
will the reasons
to want to do so
i think i think
i've understood your submission
correctly
it is to the effect that
one is aware of authorities
bb i think was mentioned
there was the ottoman case i seem to
recall
which which looked quite closely at the
whole
concept
of memorandums of assurance and so on
and that will be
if it's thought to be appropriate that
will be examined in detail at the
substantive hearing
in the meantime
the judge on friday
had to deal urgently
on perhaps limited evidence
on what
should happen in the interim period
and your submission i think is that he
was entitled on that evidence
to have to give some weight
to the mou
and envies
and if this court might or might not
have taken a similar view but that as
you reminded us at the outset of your
submission this is not why we're sitting
here today precisely
um
there's a last uh point raised by my
lunar friend for the intervener about
constructing with fulmore and
and the suggestion that someone might
find conditions so intolerable that they
might just leave
well um
again
that is
not something made good
as a real risk on the evidence before
the judge below
there wasn't evidence from appellant
five that
um
uh
he was um
bound to
um
sort of abscond because
conditions around are so difficult in
fact how could he say that when he
doesn't know what the conditions will be
like
and there are
no there is a notable vowel
about reception arrangements
ensuring that these are adequate
and you'll have seen there was evidence
before
the judge about this in the context of
malaria a ground that was raised in
writing but never really featured orally
and specific arrangements have been made
for facilities and accommodation that
are appropriate and provide safeguards
in relation to that
that was the witness statement of ms
hardy
do you have a reference yes
it's um
the
interim relief bundle oh no sorry
p-i-b the post-issue bundle
um and it's page 65.
is there a paragraph number i'm just
looking through to remind myself
of what
so i might have given you the wrong
witness it might be the armstrong
statement
um
yeah the armstrong statement is at pages
70-73
nine
i've helpfully pointed to
um paragraph nine it's page 72 all
relocated individuals will be hosted in
urban areas of kigali
which has a low prevalence of malaria in
addition accommodation facilities are
all equipped with bed nets and spraying
treatment and mosquito repellents are
available for inland outdoor use
um and the details of the prophylaxis
are in miss hardy's yes that's correct
um
so um
if i move on then to paragraph
20 of our skeleton arguments
um
essentially
um the point we're making here
responding to the third of the alleged
errors which is a
reference a reliance on fb afghanistan
um
what my learner friends thought to do is
take a
sort of
a statement about the usual situation
referring to one context
and suggest that it's a universal
principle
even in very different contexts
what fb was talking about
is the usual kind
of in
immigration removal case
where what is alleged is if you like
direct reformat
that someone is being returned
to their country of origin where they
are at risk
the moment they set off the plane
and that is not as the judge below
explained the situation here
we're dealing with a different situation
where the principal risk being discussed
is indirect reform
due to deficiencies in a refugee status
determination procedure that won't be
complete
uh in uh the interim period of six weeks
so it's just that they're just a dif
it's just a different context
just to be clear of what that submission
amounts to
if we were at the substantive hearing
in the high court
it may or may not be
open to the claimants to argue that
there's no material distinction of
principle between direct and indirect
rafale
if they wish to they will no doubt argue
that chahal applies to indirect refuge
there's a real risk
but an fb fb afghanistan they'll say
but i think yours your fundamental
submission is that when they were near
the trial stage
we're at the interim stage and the
fundamental starting point is i read the
judge's judgment
was his
uh analysis of the facts
that
there was likely to be a fairly short
interim period
pending the
judgment of the high court
on the substantive here
precisely yes
and um short period or not may not
matter if you're going to a country
where you claim to face risk immediately
it does matter in this context yeah
that's your fundamental point yeah
um
and then um
the other um
submissions were really ones about
weight i'm in a moment going to look
through my notes and see what all
submissions i need to respond to
um
paragraph 21 for example
um
plainly
the judge was entitled
to look at the interim period up to the
hearing
it will then be for others to decide if
there is
a
order to bring them back whether that
order should be stayed or not and that
decision can be taken in the light of
the evidence then
so
the possibility of onward appeals is
really neither here nor there the judge
was right to focus on that
interim period
um
i think at this moment i might just turn
to
um
the
notes i have if my computer turns on
again
um and see what which
all submissions i recorded that i should
respond to
um
perhaps before i do that i'll just say
briefly on ground three
um
that
for the reasons we've given in paragraph
25 of our skeleton argument
if
um the appellants fail on grounds one
and two
they must also fail on ground three of
their appeal
because if the judge was entitled to
refuse interim relief
to c10 now a5 he must also been entitled
to refuse generic interim relief
which would have prevented removal even
in other cases which are not materially
different
and and as for the mismatch the judge
was right
about this there is a mismatch
between ground one
and a claim for generic relief
that would prevent any
uh removals
tomorrow
because even if ground one succeeded
and there were flaws in one or more of
the cpit reports or assessments
it wouldn't follow
that every single inadmissibility
decision
was
flawed or vitiated by that
the whole point of these inadmissibility
decisions is they are individual
decisions
and so it is quite possible
that
a
the cpic inaudible i've seen what you
said about the secret report
and the further evidence you
you point to or whatever it is
but i still think that um rwanda is a
safe country for you
so
there is a mismatch between the
allegations in relation to the sort of
general assessments and the notion that
there should be a blank conjunction on
anyone being removed regardless of the
contents of the decision in relation to
them
mr
submits that
if you're right
you could never have a challenge to a
policy
and you can in public law he says
um what's your answer to that um that's
a non-sequitur at his point
you can have a challenge to a policy but
even if you have a challenge to a policy
it doesn't follow
that every single individual decision
which refers to that policy is unlawful
it is perfectly possible
in this instance to have an individual
decision which says
which doesn't rely on the flawed aspects
of the policy
which has regard to
evidence
sort of
this is so hypothetical i mean if you're
right
sorry if if mr hussein is right
that the um
assessment of rwanda is a safe third
country for these purposes which is the
starting point for all the
individualized decisions
um is flawed because there's no capacity
and no resource there are no
interpreters there aren't enough lawyers
there are no trained decision makers
then it's not possible for
individualized decisions to be
lawful is it but if you're right that it
is a safe starting point that there may
be other features in relation to the
individualized decision making that
renders a particular
individual not appropriate to go to
rwanda
well then it's a different it's a
different situation but we we just can't
know until the substantive decision we
can't know the substantive hearing so
yes i mean it depends on
what the nature of the the the flaws are
in the
any kind of general assessment i mean i
should say these cpic reports are common
in immigration context this is obviously
an un
context is different from many others
but it's commonly the case that you have
a general um report on the country
conditions
which is available to decision makers
and um
yes if that report is very seriously
wrong it may lead to um a lot of
decisions being wrong
and that's something that will be
explored no doubt in deports if on the
other hand there are um
not um
major problems with the report
and
decisions may well still be possible to
be made lawfully not withstanding
whatever flaws there are
so but yes i i agree with the essence of
my lady's point that this is just an
another thing that needs to be decided
at the at the final that that may be
right
but i think the way mr hussein puts it
is uh on any view whether or not one
accepts the word compelling
on any of you the judge has determined
that there is a serious issue to be
tried on ground one
and ground one
is not confined to the facts of any
individual case so that if ground one
ultimately turns out to be right
and the other court says that in a final
judgment
then the whole system
is visited so it's mr hussein so what he
says is that given that that is on the
horizon
in about six weeks time
when you're conducting the balance of
convenience
he says it clearly falls in favor of
erring on the side of caution not not
sending any individual back and
therefore again against their will he
accepts that if they consent then they
can go
but otherwise he says there's nothing
specific
to any
particular individual in ground one and
therefore there's no mismatch in the
arguments
well this is why i say ground three
doesn't really add to ground one because
the sort of premise of all of this is
um his first ground appeal is right and
there's a fundamental error you should
interfere with in
the assessments of
the prospects of jr ground one i see
thank you very much
um so forgive me i'm i'm going back
over my notes um
um my learner friend made much of a
particular adjective that the judge used
described
the
effect of removal on
the individual appellant
and he criticized i think both the words
onerous and the word arduous
it's fair to say to be fair to the judge
he also refers to distress
and
this sort of criticism of
language given in an extemporary
judgment very short
very intense time pressure really
doesn't begin to
demonstrate an error of principle
plainly the judge gave serious
consideration
to the witness evidence of the
individual propellant
and the effect of removal on him cannot
be said that he left out of account a
relevant factor
do you want to say anything specific in
relation to a submission mr hussein made
about the inherent
effects of
detention
and
forcible removal and he says that's a
serious interference with human dignity
well i'll deal with them one by one
detention
um uh detention
when one's focusing on the balance of
convenience one's talking about
whether or not appellant five should be
removed tomorrow
and the reality is
that
if anything
his detention will be longer
if interim relief is granted
because
once the decision is made they'll have
to be consideration of it certainly it
can't be said that the 10th century will
be shorter let's put it that way because
if he's removed he'll only be detained
until tomorrow till the removal takes
place if the removal directions are
cancelled there needs to be a decision
on
whether he should be released in light
of that
and that depends on considering whether
removal might still be imminent
and it's
at least possible
that removal could still be imminent
even if tomorrow was not the date of
removal it's something that needs to be
considered and
i'm sure the court will have experience
of how long these decisions
generally take
uh there's what's called a um
a period of grace for the secretary of
state to consider the change of
circumstances that period of grace can
vary but it tends to be
anything between a few hours and and a
week but um it's certainly not clear on
the evidence that
um
that
[Music]
there's a substantial impact on the
length of detention as a result of
whether or not to
remove and in any event
um
that's
um
uh
yeah so so
if i'm then move on to the to the
substantial interference with human
dignity
that is um in my submission
um
another way
of describing in different language
the
very real
human
effect of such a decision
which
the judge was plainly aware of and
conscientiously thought about
the distress as he put it
it's just a more
if you like colorful way of putting the
distress that the judge took into
account
thank you
and finally um
can i just say in response to the
submissions from my learned friend from
the intervenor
i do not say
that the unhcr
has changed its position or that its
views can be discounted
the secretary state recognizes
that unhcr has raised concerns
and has taken steps to address those
concerns
that is what for example the note verbal
is all about
um
there was uh
finally a submission my london friend mr
hussein made for the appellants
that
um
my lord lord justice singh pointed out
perhaps didn't really need to develop so
perhaps i don't really need to respond
but
i i i when i used the word illegal in my
in our skeleton argument
um
i was of course referring
um of course i had in mind article 31 of
the refugee convention
which prevents
there being penalties save in certain
circumstances and one of those
circumstances is where the person has
not come directly
and so
ex-hypothesis when i was talking about
people who have not come directly
i i think it is fair to say
that the
journeys are illegal but in any event it
doesn't turn on that
the the judge's decision didn't turn on
that adjective
you i don't think you said did you that
the journey is criminal no i don't know
i i think i i the way i read it maybe
wrongly was what you were making you
just making the point that it's not a
regular
process i'm grateful that is exactly
what i meant
my lord i i think i have two minutes
i would die no you oh no i have 15
minutes you have nothing
you don't have to take it i've been i'm
working to a completely different title
in my head um
i could therefore if you think it would
be helpful to go back
to paragraph 80
and perhaps i'll just do that and i
still won't take 15 minutes
so where's the page
so it's um in the um
post-issue bundle
and it's page 24 of that
um and we have paragraph 18 there on
page 24 and this is my london friend mr
hussein for the appellants
take you through these sub paragraphs
um and um
power 18 a is about people being denied
access to asylum procedures
um well for the reasons the judge gave
that doesn't seem to be
a likely problem in relation to or in
the context of
someone rwanda has expressly accepted
that they will accept
their
asylum claim
and the same is true of b and none of
the individuals certainly a5 doesn't
claim to be
in this category of lgbtiq
um
see evidence about well concerns about
impartiality
can be addressed in due course with
evidence and evidence that can go to for
example the independence of the
judiciary at the second
tier of the appeal process
the
lack of representation by a lawyer
for asylum seekers during panel
deliberations
on their case
well there is lawyer access at the
appeals stage and
this is an issue that no doubt will come
to at the trial but that is sufficient
it's all for example that is required
uh under the relevant eu directives and
unhcr handbook
reasons for negative decisions are not
provided that's specifically dealt with
by the note of a val
f appeals against rejection are made to
the minister
um and that raises concerns about
independence
but um
certainly it'll be our position at the
substantive hearing those concerns are
met by the further tier of appeal to the
high court
g
efficiency and timeliness of the
assignment procedure is a concern the
decision is taking up to one to two
years to be issued in some cases and in
recent years there's only been one
eligibility officer tasked to prepare
all cases again that's that's a point on
funding which will come down to evidence
for the substantive hearing about
whether there are now in place resources
um
it certainly doesn't help on the uh
points that the parents wish to make on
the balance of convenience and the
suggestion that there's a risk of
refurbishment in six weeks
but are you saying there is the funding
and there is the capacity or are you
saying you don't know because you
haven't got the evidence yet but you'll
get it in due course well i i i was
reluctant that this
um interim stage to make sort of
submissions without evidence to then
point to but yes that will be our case
that there is sufficient capacity to
meet
the assurances in the novel we wouldn't
have there would be no point frankly in
negotiating assurances you didn't think
the other person could actually meet
right
h
insufficient access to interpreters
throughout process again specifically
dealt with in the note for val
and then
i is again about
capacity
again a matter of evidence for
the trial
and then there's the fact jay unhr has
not been able to systematically monitor
the quality of decision-making
and not been permitted to observe the
first instance committee
um
i don't think it follows that they
wouldn't be able to observe any
uh appeal hearings in any event that can
be a
matter of evidence in due course and
there will be no doubt evidence
as to the monitoring committee
um
um i i i understand that um the evidence
was that there hasn't
been sorry but i think my friend is
making this point that the unhr is
complaining about
not having access not just the first
stage but the second stage the appeals
to the minister but my point is still
good it doesn't mean they wouldn't have
access to the third stage if you like
the appeal to the high court in any
event this is yet again
an issue
for evidence
and that evidence will no doubt cover
the um
uh
monitoring committee what it does what
it looks at what kind of level of
assurance it can provide
um when we went through the note from a
bowel there was a point about how people
could make complaints
um about the asylum process
and so one of the points of the
monitoring committee is that they can
look at complaints and how they are
dealt with
and so it will be in our our case that
they that
um suitable vigilance if you like it is
um available both through the munching
committee and otherwise but that's
something that's going to have to wait
uh for the um substantive hearing
before you
finish can you just help us with
uh the facts uh
in relation to tomorrow's flight
uh
i think when you submitted your skeleton
argument yesterday
you indicated that the number
had come down to eleven correct people
including the fifth appellant before us
yes but no longer the fourth appellant
correct
um because
as i mentioned earlier this may or may
not be accurate but i've certainly read
in the times this morning that in fact
that number's now diminished even
further
are you able to help us with how many
people currently
we're talking about for tomorrow the
last time i uh received instructions it
was 11. yes i have no information that's
the basis well that's that's normal
that's the basis on which we will
proceed thank you um we are being asked
by mr hussein not only to grant interim
relief in uh
in favor of the fifth appellate
but also
the other ten people on tomorrow's
flight it doesn't go beyond that but he
does ask for that is there anything
specific you want to say in response to
that well um it's all very well saying
it's just for the flight tomorrow um i
suppose i make two points
um
one point is the flight tomorrow is
important
um
the
and this is something the judge
fully understood and rightly recognized
this is a policy which is intended
to
defer
to to to deter
dangerous and unnecessary journeys
journeys
from safe third countries
by people who don't need to make that
journey to be safe
they can claim in france or wherever it
is
so this is a policy which if it works
could save lives as well as disrupting
the model of traffickers
so
even if we're just talking about
cancelling a flight tomorrow
there is a prejudice to the public
interest
there is a
prejudice to
the
enactment
of decisions
that may
have that deferent effect
the judge understood that and recognized
that and so that's my first point
prejudice to public interest even if
it's just talking about the flight
tomorrow the second point is
realistically
if my loaded friend gets
um
an injunction preventing any removal
without informed consent on the flight
tomorrow
then he'll be able to get the same
injunction
in relation to any other scheduled
flight before the substantive hearing
he can just turn up
with his copy and pasted arguments to
that effect
on his grounds and indeed
on that supposition
secretary of state might voluntarily
take a certain attitude knowing what the
attitude of the um
law is
what the answer of the course is yes of
course yes
or might come back with
some additional evidence
to plug what are said to be some of the
gaps
today i suppose that that is possible
yes but do we do we know anything about
the other ten
um
i
personally can't say much about the
other things that they haven't made an
application no what what sorry what uh
one thing i
i'll there's a lot of people behind me
and i hope they'll correct me if i'm
wrong but um there is another um
application for injunctive relief taking
place at 2pm
from asylum aid and
there is evidence
um i believe that the secretary is
submitted
on which deals with the other ten and
the situation of the other ten
i i understand
that all of them have lawyers from what
i understand from that evidence but i'll
be correct if i'm wrong and that's
something that is really properly for
the judge hearing that the other
application
and i and i have seen
that um
at least one of them has made their own
application for um injunctive relief i
do not know how many of the other ten
have or the other nine i suppose it is
can i just check if my lady or my lord
have any more questions
thank you very much thank you
yeah mr hussein
would you like to reply
my lord
thank you very much
on ground
one
i have four points
the first point
concerns the effective
concession
that i referred to
about the
secret state's errors
with regard to unhcr oversight and
participation
in
the rwanda plan
mr dunlop said
look a5
hasn't got the letter
so all is well
we say not so
inadmissibility letters
simply have no reasoning
but it is
with great respect alice in wonderland
stuff
to suggest
that the
misattribution
of uhcr's views
in the general assessment
would not have a very significant impact
on decision makers
i think what he said was that there'd
been investigations and seven letters
were found to contain my lady
what happens if you look at the
papers and i appreciate
we've gone very quickly
what happens is you get
screened
there's a notice of intent
within seven days you've got to provide
quote unquote evidence
to displace
the general assessment seven days later
the secretary state takes about three or
four decisions
the first decision
is that
you're inadmissible
the second decision
is that rwanda is a safe third country
the third decision if you make a human
rights claim
and often people haven't it seems if
they haven't got access to lawyers
quickly enough if you make a human
rights claim you then get
the em eritrea letter i showed you
which says
you haven't pointed in your seven days
to serious operational difficulties in
rwanda
a paradigm that applies to member states
of the eu
because
unhcr have not pointed to serious
operational errors that is just false
but what he said was that they've done
an investigation and there were seven
such letters i imagine
and i would ask you to accept that that
is every single letter
where the individual has had the
wherewithal or the lawyers have had the
wherewithal
to
make a human rights claim in the clients
that i represented
all eight of them over the last
uh
four days
two have made human rights claims
two have got that em error eritrea
letter
which has that expressly
false
claim in it
but we respectfully submit
that it is really fanciful to suggest
that the
misattribution of a misdescription
of unhcr's views
does not have an obvious impact
on all decisions
a false green light has been given to
this plan
because
the plan
is predicated
centrally
on unhcr's
endorsement
there's a lot of vigorous shaking of
heads on the other side well it is the
fact that your factual assertions
well my lord i showed you the material
you did
yes i showed you the passages in the
general assessment
where there are claims about uh
oversight
involvement participation support
safeguarding all of those claims are
wrong i think i think that what was
being
contested albeit silently
was your assertion that anybody who had
access to lawyers and had raised a human
rights claim would have received
the letter to which you take offense
well that is then the secretary of state
ought to show
it cases where that hasn't happened
because they are template letters the
two references i gave you i think it was
to claimant iv and claimant 10 they are
near identical letters
near identical
and they are letters that i have seen in
the context of eu returns to under
dublin
year ameritrader is the eu dublin case
it's been applied to this context
and the glosses
unhcr do not have a problem
my lord's my lady my second that brings
me to my second point
which is that it is tempting but wrong
to conceive of our ground one
as simply an outcome ground because if
it's just an outcome ground mr dunlop
can say never mind that we do not have a
scintilla of evidence
a scintilla of evidence
to controvert the material that we have
provided and uhcr has provided he can
say wait until we provide the evidence
but the ground one is not confined to
outcome
it is also about process
and the legality and rationality and the
team side compliance about the process
it is difficult to see i don't need to
say i'm bound to win but i do absolutely
say
my second point that i have a compelling
case on ground one
when i say that as part of my
rationality challenge you took account
secretary of state of a manifestly
irrelevant consideration
there is what's the answer to that that
your hcr have just made up their
communication of views that that the
secretary's own minutes are false
is that the answer
we'll see what the evidence is
so that is why i say
that ground one
has compelling merit third point the
question of whether a group a legal
ground of challenge
is
has compelling prospects or serious
prospects is not a matter
which is anything other than a legal
issue it's a legal question
you apply legal analysis
to determine whether or not this ground
has strength
and how much strength it has
if not sure i understand that submission
so with respect
it is commonplace
uh in this country
uh if you if you go down uh the corridor
to court 37 there will be a judge in the
high court dealing with interim
applications every day
and all the time they will be having to
make assessments
about whether there is a serious issue
to be tried
it's not necessarily a matter of law
it'll often be a factual issue
in civil i was going to come to a
decision with civil and public law
matters but public floor
i'm not going to get anywhere on the
factual challenge to the secretary of
state's
decision in a public law proceeding my
errors
ex-hypothesis have to be errors of law
i have to say to you there's an error of
law
due process
deficit or
rationality
problem and i've said that
that's a question of law
and you can look at
that as well as
the lower judge it's not doesn't depend
upon a factual evaluation at all
we've respectfully said it may it may do
part of it maybe but essentially it's a
legal question and if it's not a legal
question my alternative submission is
then with respect to him the judge was
plainly wrong for the reason i just gave
because ground one is not simply an
outcome
ground it's a process ground the process
it is difficult to imagine the case
where the process could be more
obviously flawed
where you are saying i have the
impromature
of the
specialist agency in this area and in
fact you don't
across key
parts of your plan
the fourth point i wanted to make
is that for understandable forensic
purposes mr dunlop says serious issue is
only a threshold question you get past
that it goes away and you're into
balance i've got submissions even if
that's right
we say we have a compelling case for
interim really but my primary argument
is it's wrong
and the reason it's wrong is because
this is taken from cyanide mother care
civil cases
civil cases where at your starting point
you don't allocate a priori weight
to the public body
exercising its public function
but in public law you do
and i gave you references
high authority
lord hoffman
in the jamaica bank case lord walker in
the congo where they both say it is
absolutely legitimate to look at
prospects and when you're looking at as
a matter of first principles
it it makes sense because when you're
looking at
achieving least injustice
then one can see why i would want want
to do that
round two
uh my lord's my lady six points
firstly this is not just a factual
disagreement
we say balance of convenience error of
approach error of approach
to united states
i know you're very mine
we're finishing at one o'clock
approach to united star's evidence
lack of scrutiny
error as to the relevant period
approach to the mou and whether there
was sound objective bases for it to that
it would be followed
verification error of approach
second point and this is really telling
with great respect mr dunlop accepts
that my client
may by reason of systemic bias
be
rejected
but it's all okay
because you've got your appeal
there are sorry
i didn't understand him to accept the
first
said in response as i understood it
forgive me if i'm wrong to my lord-lord
justice singh's question
or was it my lady's question i think
forgive me he said yes that may happen
but the fact that that may happen the
first
question that arises is why on earth
would one
visit that for six weeks on an
individual
in circumstances where
that individual is a torture victim
what about the interference with human
dignity to know that you have had your
refugee
claim
dismissed on a
on a biased basis
i know you've got that wrong you've got
a limited amount of time to make six
points and there may be more points on
ground three i don't know uh i i think
that you are proceeding i'm afraid on a
false promise okay this is a
hypothetical okay question that i put
mr dunlop didn't accept this as a
factual premise he was simply making
the point the the submission that even
if even if this were to happen
it wouldn't all finish within six weeks
we have a note that he said it may all
be right but i will accept i i will make
the submission
the evidence shows
that there is
at least a real risk of a biased
decision rejecting my iraqi client's
case
it doesn't matter
on the balance of committees whether
that will sequentially lead to reform
because that very fact
if it transpires and there's a real risk
that it would
on uncontroverted material
is a very serious interference with
human dignity
that's the first point
the second point is that if that happens
then
the second state has to on the reformal
problem and it's a subset of ground one
has to put all her eggs in the appeal
basket
the appeal can go very quickly
the references
interim relief bundle
uh page 176 4.3.1
first instance
within 15 days appeal
which is non-independent
within
five to ten days
and that's a senior rwandan official
saying that it can go that quickly and
then the reference to appeals on that
page is to high court appeals and there
is no precedent for any high court
appeal as of now
what was the page reference again
internal relief
interim relief 176.
then as regards type the third point as
regards timing
we say it was wrong of the judge
to adopt a binary approach and say
all the risk outside this confined
period falls away
you have that point
but the fourth point
is that
the fb case
it doesn't it doesn't matter whether
it's direct or indirect reform or it
doesn't alter the legal test we know
that from the book diet the great bug
daikai case the case that gave rise to
the most anxious scrutiny principle
itself concerned a question of indirect
reform you don't alter the legal test
the problem is the risk
the the reality of the risk not how you
get to it whether directly or indirectly
the fifth point
the idea that if
removal directions were cancelled that
would prolong the tension
well
hardy will see principles might have
something to say about that
executive detention
is anathema to our law as my lords my
lady
well know
and
then the last point public interest
the idea that these are unnecessary
journeys
because you found safety is flatly
inconsistent
with
absolutely anyone who's looked at the
refugee convention the drafters the
academics uhcr lord justice simon brown
and nadimi lord bingham and asphalt they
all say individuals are not pieces of
cargo they have they are moral agents
under the refugee convention they have
some element of choice as to where they
will claim and then my lords my lady on
ground three
uh i will make just
two points
as a regards
uh my mark at appellate five
as we
in
in the manner in which these uh
proceedings have been conducted
i have just been
received
a
uh
the news that his removal is going to be
maintained
and there's been a decision we've just
got it
it
it appears that torture has been
considered that the removal hasn't been
deferred because rwanda has a
functioning health care system
and it doesn't raise any issues we say
this is not the way
that an individual in my client's
position
or
should be placed
with absolutely
what are we supposed to do to move the
court again if we think there is merit
this is far too late that is what the sb
case was about the complete lack of
notice between removal
the decision
and the flight
just check if my lady has any questions
very grateful to all concerned
we
intend to rise now
there will be
a decision and a judgment
inevitably that's going to be an
unreserved
judgment so it will be read out
um doing the best
that i can about the timing of that it
will be not before 3 30
so
i hope it will be at 3 30 but i know you
will understand if we're not back in
quarter three four
and we are extremely grateful for the
expedition that you've engaged
you